i can't tell you just walking around um
really anywhere
uh people recognize me and uh are
excited to see me and
and the rest of it and one of the things
they'll always say to me is they'll say
love ubi
don't be like that and it happens to me
frequently enough where i guarantee that
these people are not hanging out on
forums
or uh you know uh that like they're not
they don't strike me as activists and so
it seems like there's a ton of energy
and one of my projects now is to try and
figure out how to both grow that energy
and also
translate it into action and policy
there's so much that can happen at the
at the local level that um that that i
don't think enough people like
appreciate where
you know if it may sound like you can't
you know get your
member of of congress or you know
something to do anything
um but there's certainly things like um
you know even another thing that
happened in this
this uh the pandemic was the mayor's for
guaranteed income launched and then
suddenly
that opened the avenue for people to
contact their mayors and encourage them
to
join this and launch it that's another
thing you can do right
in addition to the march you can yell at
your mayor be like hey why aren't you
part of mayors for guaranteed income
and the way that works is you know you
get mayors on board and then suddenly
that lends this idea more credence
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks everybody it
is monday july 19th happy monday this is
your co-host zach grauman
before we get today's episode just a
quick reminder
we've got basically some really exciting
stuff coming
down the pike this fall uh andrew's got
exciting stuff i've got exciting stuff
uh carly and yang gang friends have
exciting stuff it's going to be a really
exciting fall this summer
we're going to be trying a number of new
formats but we're going to keep coming
at you
yang on mondays and carly riley and
myself
on thursdays with variety of different
formats do not
miss it it's going to be great i think
you're going to like we're coming out
with and you're going to love what we're
coming out with this fall
anyway today's episode's on universal
basic
income and cash relief with a o.g
he's not only og yang gang this guy was
basically
the foremost thought leader on basic
income
in the country scott sands
joins the podcast is a long time overdue
we wanted to do it we wanted to do it
right
and this was done right right now scott
sands joins andrew yang
on yang speaks right now
and we are back and it's my pleasure to
welcome to yang speaks
the og the original ubi godfather
my inspiration uh and educator
for many things scott santans scott
welcome
hey andrew good to see you it's great to
see you as well so the most important
thing is did you just tie the knot did
you just get married did you just get
back from some
uh some very uh ground-bound honeymoon
like uh tell us more
tell us more i did i did i got married
on
uh june 16th and uh got married
on a beach in florida uh we did like a
big like
over two week long road trip driving to
a bunch of different places
that's fantastic congratulations man um
were you with
uh your now wife when you and i were
hanging out in new orleans
uh those years ago yeah we've been
together since uh 2012.
so before i was even into ubi before you
were into ubi
uh can you all imagine all the ladies
listening to this your boyfriend
coming back and being like hey there's
this thing universal basic income
we should totally make it happen i'm
gonna get myself one you actually
got yourself one by the time you and i
met
in 2017
you already had a universal basic income
and it kind of appointed yourself the
prototype which i have to say is the
greatest thing about
the greatest thing of all time so i want
you to reflect
on that time in new orleans uh
when i got a drink with you
and i was like hey i'm gonna run for
president on universal basic income do
you remember that
oh absolutely yeah i'll always remember
that that's a that's a big day
and then so what did you think when i
said it i was extremely excited uh
about that that prospect and it was
already like my mind was already
worrying was um already like buzzing
about uh
the idea of you like on the debate stage
uh
on a national you know platform talking
about basic income i was just thinking
like how
like how much that would push the
movement forward it for suddenly like
everyone um watching to be like
hearing this debate happen and other
candidates would have to like have a
stance on basic income and everything
so it was really exciting and i remember
you having that reaction i have to say
scott
your reaction was so pure and unusual
because
there was no uh skepticism or anything
uh at all you were just like sure
like and your mind was going towards the
practicalities
so how did you first get into ubi and
then make it happen for yourself
because it really is kind of a dream
yeah yeah i got back i got into it back
in 2013
and it was really through kind of the
same route that so many have
been introduced to through you which was
the technology route
which is this idea of automation the
impacts of automation
the potential future um the effects of
it
and how to you know essentially make
technology work for us
and it was this actually through the
front page of reddit there was a
conversation
about like how no one was talking about
how quickly things were going what that
was leading to
and so through that i started i was
introduced to the idea
of basic income um through actually the
reading the book called mana by marshall
brain which was about like
um the automation of middle management
really and what that would
do like starting there and going on and
uh yeah just
read more about it and learned about
like the history of it i had no idea
about what happened like under nixon and
stuff i had no idea about the pilots
that happened in the us and canada just
fascinated to look into all the evidence
and you know looked into like the
philosophy behind it
and looked into just really learned more
about the way the existing safety net
works
and after all that was just like well
this is an extremely important idea
not just for the future but something
that we should have done actually
decades ago
that we need to do immediately and
reaching that conclusion i was like
i can't spend any time on anything else
because this is just too important of an
issue
i love it so you read this book mana and
then you said this has to happen
immediately and then you said i'm going
to devote my life to making it happen
uh i mean that's pretty extraordinary
um so i i want people to get a sense as
to
who and what you are now but scott is
the most prolific
universal basic income advocate on the
internet
and has essentially this compendium of
materials
uh for everything under the sun ubi
related
has addressed any uh
question uh like ten times over
it's like built like this this awesome
library
um and and so back to 2013
uh what were your next steps and when
did you actually start getting
a universal basic income for yourself
yeah so one of the first things i did
was i got involved as a moderator on the
basic income subreddit
um and i tried to you know engage in
those conversations
find like materials to post there and
also
you know consume as many much materials
as i could to learn more
then eventually i got to the point where
i felt i was comfortable enough to start
like writing about basic income and
trying to
basically serve as like a popularizer
and like translator of academic
materials to try to explain things
simpler in a more shareable consumable
way
and then around late 2014
was discovered like patreon and i
thought well this is like
actually a really interesting kind of
twist on kickstarter
where instead of like trying to to to
crowdfund like one
stack of something for something this
was like a
an ongoing monthly crowdfunding
and i thought well this is you know
potentially a brilliant way of
crowdfunding a monthly basis income for
perpetuity
so i decided to to go for that
and it's funny too like that was
actually that conversation i had with uh
with my wife katie
uh you know at that time was just like
um uh i have this idea i think that i
can
i can i think i gotta i can achieve this
and i could focus on this full time if i
can do it
and you know i'm like well you know she
thought well you know maybe
just she was hesitant and uh you know
doubtful
but uh you know i did it and you know we
look back at that conversation too
it's like well yeah like we sure enough
you put your mind to it and you did it
so when you say you did it you went out
to the reddit community
and said hey guys i want to popularize
universal basic income so chip in 25
bucks
a month and then enough people do it
then i can just do this all the time was
that the pitch or what was the pitch
um yeah essentially so i the the
when i set up my patreon it was like so
the goal of this is to crowdfund a basic
income so that i can focus
full-time on basic income and so i
launched that in late 2014
and it took all of 2015 to you know
build it
over time and then i achieved my goal of
a thousand dollars per month
um starting in january of 2016. so it
was also interesting that process
where you know i would write something
and then you know you put at the end
you can support me on patreon and you
know doing podcasts and stuff you get
the word out
and then just slowly over time more
people would uh join in and start
donating say a dollar a month five
dollars a month or something
and that process was actually
educational in itself
because you know when i was at say 400
per month like just that's not a
thousand dollars per month but
because i knew that 400 per month would
be there on the first of next month
then that in itself was like this
reduction of insecurity
like this kind of feeling like that
that's going to be there and it's going
to make a difference and
so that's even why i feel as i feel
about like smaller basic incomes or you
know people say oh a thousand dollars a
month that's nothing that's like well
no like even 500 is really something 400
to something 300 something it's all
something to actually know that it's
going to be there to have that stable
source of security i just want to say
just a total aside
i was just notified that i was going to
get a 164
check for the korean royalties
uh of the war on normal people and i was
like 164 dollars
great
so i'm i'm with you it's like you know
like everything is something
yeah you know like that it it felt
meaningful
um and if that was coming in every month
it would be uh
tremendously impactful for just about
anyone i think yeah
absolutely so it takes you a year to get
this thousand bucks a month
um we might as well do this segue right
now if someone wants to support you they
go to scottshantons.com
yeah it's a patreon.com or you can find
me at through my website at
scottsantons.com
i'm i'm a contributor
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like me you're always trying
to better yourself in some way but
sometimes you're
a little hesitant to sign up for like a
full like multi-week class or dive into
a full new topics that might be a large
waste of time
and particularly money and i want to
talk to you about skillshare which is a
sponsor of this podcast because it is a
fun way and easy way to learn to create
without a massive commitment what i love
so skillshare simply has
whether you're a dabbler a pro a
hobbyist or a master you're creative and
you can go online
and take these classes for all these
different types of skills so experience
real improvement with hands-on projects
and classes designed
for real life it's incredibly affordable
especially when it comes to these pricey
in-person classes and workshops i'm
talking about there's one on there right
now
that i'm taking it's by my one of my
favorite authors guy kawasaki wrote the
book called the art of the start
and it's basically how you turn your
ideas into high growth businesses it
cuts the noise out of entrepreneurship
how to start something yourself
it is awesome there's a ton of other
classes on there about building an etsy
shop or learning photography and a ton
of things you can do
right now so here's the deal explore
your creativity at skillshare.com
yang and get one month free of premium
membership get that free trial from us
the one month of premium membership at
skillshare.com
yang
[Music]
[Applause]
so scott was the prototype and had been
making this case
since before i arrived on the scene and
when i was educating myself
uh in 2017 scott was the first
place on the internet i stopped and i
remember this vividly scott i looked at
your
social media and i said wow scott
sanders has a hundred thousand followers
that means a hundred thousand people
must love universal basic income
that's what i thought i got together
with you and other people
there's a a universal basic income
community
that has grown
and one of the things that we're going
to talk about in a little bit is the
state of affairs right now
because you're a senior advisor to
humanity forward which has been
lobbying for cash relief on capitol hill
so we can hear about the absolute latest
uh but we'll continue on this timeline
so in 2017 you and i
uh sit down in new orleans i'm like hey
i'm gonna run for president on this and
uh and you were enthusiastic which was
not the case for
um for everyone i mean uh and i'm sure
you remember
when emails from me started popping up
into the universal basic income
uh mailing list being like hey guys
running for president
like here's what we need we need a
review
and you were always like yeah let's do
it it's great
and then other people were like uh i'm a
non-profit
like you know so like there was a small
clutch of people
on that list sir like you that were like
yeah
and like you know the subreddit was
there too but like the subreddit
it's just like the way that all this
stuff works is is you know let's say
50 000 50 000 subscribers to a subreddit
it doesn't mean like everyone's there
reading it all the time doesn't mean
that everyone's like engaging in it
doesn't mean everyone's like clicking on
the stuff so you know
you have like a it feels like there's a
lot of support but then it comes down to
like donating
then that's something different and also
it's like you know this is a
a an idea that's that is most useful to
the people who
lack the money to help make it happen
so it's like that's another barrier to
cross as well there's just a smaller
percentage of people that can actually
you know donate yeah that is a problem
for sure
in in america money talks and so the
people that
need universal basic income the most uh
aren't as visible or audible
uh you know like you wouldn't believe
some of the things that people said to
me on the trail
or even what you just said a thousand
bucks a month like you know that's not
meaningful be like well if you talk to
that person over there
i don't feel like that really they'd be
super amped about it
um so 2018 2019
happens and you were a real champion on
the trail
um that was good fun i would see you
in iowa i would see you in different
places you'd pop up
so so what was the campaign like from
your point of view
because you and i haven't really
compared notes on it except for the you
know times i'd actually see you
yeah i mean it was a real experience um
you know being able to go to iowa
to be a part of that um there on like
the
you know right before the very first
state you know voted
and um the thing that i remember
most out of that experience is just you
know getting to meet so many members of
the yang gang
in all these different cities in iowa
and as i like drove across the state
going on different places
and that's really what stuck with me is
this like feeling of
of this you know family this community
of people who
you know really wanted to make a
difference and they were there to
you know try to try to change the world
for the better
doing this this thing that was
considered to be you know impossible for
so many
and um yeah that just really stuck we
was just an incredible group
of people and just very passionate about
this idea
and um yeah it just felt like more it
felt like more
like family instead of like um you know
it was just a community
well there's a unifying spirit to
people who love universal basic income
and one of the things that i
i've grown to understand more fully is
that i think people that love universal
basic income
have a belief in humanity and a sense of
possibility
and those things are wonderful
and it's one reason why when i encounter
people who supported me uh on the
campaign
i love them like 95 times out of a
hundred
you know like really really positive
optimistic wonderful people
um and there's a sense of but
of abundance really that like we can do
this
uh if you do well that's good for me
like there's no like yo if you do well
like it somehow hurts me
which unfortunately i think is pervasive
in american life today
uh where uh the scarcity mindset is so
strong
um so i'm so glad that you had that
experience i've talked to many people
who've had the same experience i had the
same
experience so aside from the times i saw
you
in new orleans because i came back and
campaigned and that was fun
i saw you in iowa where else did you and
i hang out or where else did you
campaign during um during
that time well i mean i even think too
about our times
you know it wasn't the first time that
we met when we met here in new orleans
um you know we met previously through to
you know essentially
like the origins of the economic
security project and
um you know i remember too that uh when
we were
sitting at like the thing was called the
cash conference and uh you know spent
time to
spend some time together there um you
know sitting watching stuff and
talking about um you know making it
making it happen whereas like you know
some other people were there talking
about these smaller steps and
things it's like no we just gotta do
this
i remember that too i remember sitting
there with you and there were a couple
of other people with us
uh that um you know i'm still good
friends with
um it was a fantastic launching pad
and one of the things that happened for
me so deciding to run for president
first exploring running for president
because i i
thought well if someone else is going to
do this and make this case better than
me then you know i'm happy to not do it
um but then going around being like hey
you know what's going to do this
like everyone was like no
[Laughter]
i was like all right i guess it's me um
and so so you were pumped about it
and uh andy stern was pumped about it
um misha challenge was pumped about it
uh sir can piantino was pumped about
like there were different people who
were just like yeah yeah
yeah and a bunch of us were sitting
together at that cash conference
and i remember too like along the way
like there was a
big moment um it was just like such a
long process like you said it was like
2017 we started running and you know the
election was
2020. it's like this is such a long ramp
up
and i remember um watching
your joe rogan appearance you know as it
happened
and uh you know then i like i texted you
afterwards the
like right after i watched it it'd be
like you know this is
this is going to be like a big big thing
like that was like an incredible
appearance
and some people watching it like this is
i knew like that was gonna be a moment
and like sure enough like that was a
really big
um shift in your entire campaign and and
i would say the uli movement as a whole
yeah it was that had a historic feel as
february 2019
and the campaign did take off after that
where after that i'd get recognized on
the street regularly
my wife evelyn started joking that we
can't take you anywhere because it would
it would end up descending into you know
selfies and
and whatnot which is cool i mean i enjoy
that stuff but it was a drag for evelyn
because it would just take us forever to
get anywhere so that was
february 2019 and then the debates are
through the summer
really did that summer too was enormous
um
and then we wind up campaigning in iowa
in the winter
of 2020 uh and then the campaign ends
and then covet hits
and so at that point we started humanity
forward
that you're now an advisor to uh and we
converted to
cash relief and uh
advocacy and lobbying
[Music]
while the country has found hope as it
emerges from one of the most challenging
years in our history
dealing with adversity and finding ways
to unify
and overcome it will always be part of
our future
the new season of hope through history a
documentary podcast presentation
[Applause]
the cares act got passed and then
some time passed there have been three
checks
that have gone out and a child tax
credit that just kicked in
so 36 million families are getting 300
bucks a month now
and that's something that really should
be extended in perpetuity
i mean that that's uh that that's an
enormous part of the future
in my mind uh where do you see
the current lobbying efforts on capitol
hill uh
and how would we project forward the
movement
so yeah first of all i like
your role in this is your your campaign
for president
was just like perfectly timed for
what ended up being this disastrous
um pandemic that happened just like
right afterwards i mean it was already
starting to happen remember you know
iowa i remember reading news about
snow stuff coming in china and
everything and it
had no idea at the time that it was
going to blow up into a pandemic
and also like i remember thinking and
in writing about this too thinking that
okay when the next recession hits
then there's going to be a lot of
automation that happens as a result
people are going to lose a lot of their
jobs those jobs are going to come back
because that's what happens during
recessions
and so that will be this like catalyst
to really push basic income forward
but even thinking that i had no idea
that it would be a pandemic that would
actually be
this catalyst so that happened as it did
like just so many people becoming
unemployed
um and also even employed but losing so
much income
and you know this this massive federal
response that happened like
fortunately i i think that there's a
connection there between
this rising um popularity of basic
income
and this immediately going towards these
1200
checks and the cares act and um you know
it's like one of those things where
i don't know if that would have happened
in the same way had you not won for
president
and had the basic income movement not
been building up over the years
but it did happen that way that 1200
went out and i think that was
a game changer because then that set
this new precedent
and um sure enough it was followed the
next by 600
and again that wasn't going to happen
immediately
either like humanity forward was was
directly involved
in in the happening and i know that that
was a
moment of great pride for you to have
been involved
oh yeah i i had calls with uh with
dozens of members of congress on both
sides of the aisle
uh and uh one of the things that
always impressed them was the popularity
of cash relief
where pandemic cash relief had something
like 82 percent approval
yeah it's one of the most popular things
that the government has ever done
yeah i got a question that was 18
they're like no
right well not everyone got it
so those conversations uh
leading to actual relief for tens of
millions of americans
was one of the high points of my life
where uh you know imagine feeling like
you might have played a role in billions
of dollars going out to people i mean
it's a really good feeling
great feeling and then i was in
georgia and it ended up being one of the
central issues in the entire freaking
senate race over there where
um where the democratic candidates were
very
openly campaigning on two thousand
dollar relief checks uh and then
uh mitch mcconnell ended up getting on
board in part because he was trying to
help the republicans win
yeah i mean that was i think that was
such a uh
like that the politics around that
moment was it was just so
big where um you know you had like
mitch did not want um that to pass you
know the
the the bill that uh did pass in the
house uh
mitch was like no we're not gonna pass
two thousand dollars that's ridiculous
and um you know so then trump was like
two thousand dollars it needs to be two
thousand dollars so suddenly that shift
of the conversation and the democrats
are like trump says two thousand dollars
let's do this you know
and um so that became this huge part of
the
conversation
and sure enough like you said in georgia
they're pushing for this
and saying you know vote for us and
we're going to be able to
actually do this because mitch is going
to lose power we're going to gain power
this is the the difference in senate
power when we can get that two thousand
dollars to you
and you can see like the polling where
like that
really moved the needle where they
started saying
vote for us and we'll get you two
thousand dollars and then boom that
pushes it up
enough that um i think that they were
able to
to pull off that victory and so yeah
it's incredible that that
not only you know you were down there to
be be a part of that and
this basic income conversation the cash
was part of it
and so then we got that third check
afterwards
uh this you know 14 hour 49 check and
now that that's such a big deal that
there's three checks now
and you know the question still remains
is there going to be a fourth check and
um
you know possibly not probably not but
the possibility is out there
depending on what happens depending on
what happens to the economy in a way
that
it just wasn't part of the conversation
before and then sure enough these
monthly
checks now for parents is effectively
like basing them for kids
and that too is going to stimulate the
economy that's going to function as a
monthly stimulus payment for so many
people and so many people are going to
get used to
feeling the security from this monthly
check that's entirely independent of
work
and feel that that you know you can't
take that away that's going to be an
extremely popular program
and i think it'll get people thinking
well why don't we do more of this why
don't we make sure
that adults without kids get this too
let's just make sure everyone has this
economic security
the child property tax credit is
enormously impactful
and anything we can do to help make it
permanent
we should do one of the interesting
things is that republicans are for it
because it
felt pro-family and i agree with that
i know i mean it's me and heck anything
that gets cash into american families
hands
i'm all for um it's been
incredibly invigorating to see humanity
forward develop
into this non-partisan bipartisan
lobbying shop where uh
it's become a real player and the team
is very talented and they've hired
experienced lobbyists it reminds me of
this onion article
that really helped uh shape something
for me forever which was like the
american people hire their own lobbyist
to fight for their interests on capitol
hill and it was like this way the
american people will have
um so i feel like humanity forward has
become the people's lobbyist
that way and universal basic income is
something that
there is no natural interest group for
except for the people you know you know
it's like
who's universal basically would help
it's like well all of us it's like well
who cares about that
you know so so that this people's lobby
on capitol hill is so fascinating to me
and the fact that that's now
a permanent fixture i mean you know it's
getting support uh from
uh different players and diverse support
and anyone
who wants to support this mission you
can go to humanityforward.com and you
know
make individual contributions too um but
i have to say talking to the team at
humanity forward
uh after i got off the mayoral
um because i hadn't talked to them in a
little while um
was so uplifting
you know it it it makes me feel like
we're set to do
an enormous amount of good uh for years
and years to come
yeah absolutely there was um you know
again
one of the the
the the best things that come out of
your campaign and
to be able to launch like right during
the pandemic to get cash to people i
mean i know that that made a huge
difference in people's lives
too just getting those like the micro
grants out to people and it was just you
know immediate
it was before the government was even
getting checks out too
now we distributed 12 million dollars or
so directly to people
uh in varying amounts
and you know this is a deep question for
for us all is that if you had a choice
between taking 12 million dollars and
giving it to struggling americans which
we did do
[Laughter]
and uh taking
four million dollars and spending it on
lobbyists to try and get uh
or ads or you know mailers or whatever
the heck to try and get
a hundred billion dollars from the
government
for americans like which do you choose
uh and you know so what what we did in
real life was we said 12 million dollars
directly to people
and then you know maybe uh three or four
million
on on lobbying um you know is that the
right mix
but but that's a real thinker for the
people at home
um and when i tried to figure out the
return on investment for the six hundred
dollar
checks uh it was something like you know
over a million percent
um and one of the business truisms
is that lobbying is a very high
efficiency activity
or high impact activity where like for
every lobbying dollar
you get like 12 in economic returns it's
it's crazy
yeah if you're a multi-million dollar
like you know giant corporation like why
would you not
spend at least some percentage of your
money doing that if it can mean
you know a huge return on that
investment so yeah that's just
how it works so yeah we need to have a
people's lobbyists we need to have this
organization that's making sure that
you know instead of relying on charities
to get money to people
that the government actually does its
job and gets money to people
and that you know we shouldn't even be
having to go through this process in the
first place like you know
we should have had a basic income in
place before this pandemic even hit
we should have had you know automatic
stabilizers in place that automatically
started getting
you know kicking out unemployment boosts
to people
and you know monthly seminars checks to
people above their basic income like you
know we should
automate more of this to make sure the
government actually gets money to people
when the people need it and
it's a matter of setting that up
[Music]
okay if you suck at eating vegetables
this product is for you this episode of
yang speaks is brought to you by
athletic greens it is the most
comprehensive daily nutritional beverage
i've ever tried
it's just wonderful green powder you
throw it in some water you throw it in
some almond milk you throw it in a
milkshake you throw it in a
milkshake probably less healthy but
throw it in a smoothie
blends up it tastes good and you get all
of the vegetables you were supposed to
eat during the day all at one time so
one scoop of athletic greens gives you
75 vitamins minerals and whole food
source
ingredients like a multivitamin multi
mineral probiotic green superfood blend
and more and they all work together
to fill nutritional gaps in your diet
increase your energy and focus
and aid with digestion plus it supports
your healthy immune system
without need to take lots of products i
have a friend that tastes like
15 vitamins a day which i think is
ridiculous athletic greens knocks that
out so right now if you visit
athleticgreens.com
yang you can join health experts
athletes and health conscious go-getters
all over the world to make their daily
commitment
to their health every day and we're
giving a free one-year supply of vitamin
d and five free travel packs travel
packs or clutch
with your first purchase if you visit
our link today so that's
athleticgreens.com
yang get your free year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
today
[Music]
[Applause]
so if someone watching this at home
wants to help make the case
for cash relief because i know there are
so many people that
uh want to see this happen um and there
are different things you can do you can
the traditional thing is like write your
member of congress uh
no um they can certainly support
humanity forward uh
but like do you when someone asks you
this question like where do you send
them
yeah i mean it it there's some there's
certainly more options now
and i guess one of the questions i ask
is like you know
what is it that you want to do and
not only like what's available but even
like what skill sets do you have
that you could even create something new
like what would be
even like an enjoyable thing like a fun
thing for you to do um
you know maybe you would like to write
um something maybe you'd like
to you know as for like a you know
submit it to your local paper or maybe
you'd like to write to your members of
congress or maybe you'd like to
start up a a podcast or maybe you
already have a podcast
and like let's do like a topic about
basic income or something along those
lines like
you know there's various things that
people can do and certainly you know
getting money
to um as funding for humanity forward is
uh you know a great way to go about that
now but um and also i really like
scottsdale.com no need to feel
restricted
or scout sanders.com but also you know
income movement
um which is that incomemovement.com is
doing a lot of great stuff grassroots
organizing
people can you know be involved there
that's uh that's great and also we've
got the
you know the basic income march is
coming up here in september
and that's really exciting to see happen
again um hopefully there again be even
more people um this time than the
previous times
and that could show even more movement
so people can hey if you've
if you um if there's already something
scheduled
um and a march in your place then in
your in your area then
you know please attend it and if there
isn't then
please be that person that you know sets
it up and
um helps uh organize that so there's
there's definitely things that that
people can do that um
you know didn't really exist years ago
so you've seen
basic income grow from this marginal uh
thing no one had heard of back in 2014
let's call it in 15
16 and now in 2021 it feels to a lot of
people like we're this close i mean it
feels like that to me
you know we're sending out checks to
tens of millions of people it's like why
don't we just keep on doing it
uh you know it has grown the majority of
americans are for it
i can't tell you just walking around uh
really anywhere
uh people recognize me and uh are
excited to see me and and the rest of it
and one of the things they'll always say
to me is they'll say love ubi
don't be like that and it happens to me
frequently enough where i guarantee that
these people are not hanging out on
forums
or uh you know uh that like they're not
they don't strike me as activists and so
it seems like there's a ton of energy
and one of my projects now is to try and
figure out how to both grow that energy
and also translate it into action and
policy
so we have humanity foreign on the
lobbying side we have people who can do
things like participate in the basic
income march
uh and and organize locally um
and so now my efforts are going to go
towards trying to make it so that our
government's actually more responsive
to the will of the people because that
connection has unfortunately
been breaking down for quite some time
there's so much
that can happen at the at the local
level that um
that that i don't think enough people
like appreciate where
you know if it may sound like you can't
you know get your
member of of congress or you know
something to do anything
um but there's certainly things like um
you know even another thing that
happened in this
this uh the pandemic was the mayor's for
guaranteed income launched and then
suddenly
that opened the avenue for people to
contact their mayors and encourage them
to
join this and launch it that's another
thing you can do right in addition to
the march you can
yell at your mayor be like hey why
aren't you part of mayors for a
guaranteed income
and the way that works is you know you
get mayors on board and then suddenly
that lends this idea more credence and
then also you've got like city councils
that are
that are looking at this you've got like
also yesterday was a big day too because
california passed the first bill for a
publicly funded
like ongoing guaranteed income uh
program which is
for foster youth and that too came from
a pilot
that started in santa clara county that
came from
um i'm a board for the funder for
humanity the jailboard uh funder free
humanity
and that was a pilot that was started
there which is this little pilot
for a small group of of uh youth aging
out of the foster youth system
and that did so well and also it
happened during the pandemic california
little looks at this um rising
popularity
that again came out of stockton and they
say well let's do this
statewide and like a permanent thing to
make sure that
that those aging out of the foster youth
system have a basic income for three
years
and now that's a real thing like that is
a thing now as of yesterday so again
it's just amazing to watch these how
something can be
you know small and grow over time one
pilot may seem like a small thing but it
can grow into much
bigger things and i think that over time
we're going to see this stuff
get bigger and bigger and all of that
lends more momentum to the whole thing
to get more people
on board more organizations on board and
then once you get
those kind of organizations then they're
putting pressure on the members of
congress
that would usually not listen to people
and now they feel they have to
because the ones who hold influence over
them are saying look you need to do this
and that's really how stuff gets done so
if someone comes to you and they just
want to find out more about universal
basic income
uh and then you say okay here are the
things you should do um so for you back
in the day it was mana
for me it was raising the floor by andy
stern is there like a
starter you give them like hey read this
book
i mean certainly you are the internet's
library on this so
like i i refer people to scoutsands.com
but like what what
what what do you yeah uh tell people to
do
like i mean that was the that was the
the reasoning that i even
started writing uh because it was like
this kind of a long map
project of i want to cover all of these
different
frequently asked questions i want to
cover these different angles
and put it all into one place and so i
have that faq
on my blog and i refer to people to that
a lot and i even
you know because i have various articles
for different
commonly asked questions then i just
share those a lot as ways to
um get people introduced to the idea
so yeah like that was instead of like
stopping or not doing anything in in
writing
um a book like you know i could have
spent years or something writing that
i just wanted to get little pieces of
shareable content out
and create almost like a table of
contents for
for your multiple normal questions that
are asked
and i think now at some point i'll
hopefully transform that into a book
here in the immediate future too to make
that even easier but
the short answer to this god is you just
say like hey uh read yang's book
you know you have to go through all of
this like that's good that's that's a
good intro too for sure
and also andy stern's book there's uh
and that's the thing too is there's a
there's just a great many books that can
um
that can introduce people in different
ways
um and it's important to match that book
with them so you know maybe someone
doesn't care about the automation
argument
maybe they care about you know the way
the welfare system works right now their
existing safe net they would say hey
read you know tyranny of kindness by
teresa finicello like uh
that's like a great book to read eric
you know who's doing a sequel to that
book right now is annie lowry andy
lowry's apparently
deep in how the welfare system works um
so
uh really excited to see what she she
finds out i i like where you're going
with this this so this is an important
task thought
so what you have to do is you have to
say like well what kind of person a
reader are you and then be like if
you're this right
read yang's book if you're this uh read
uh teresa's book if you're this like
that that's very interesting yeah or
listen to this podcast you know if
you're not a reader then listen to this
or if you prefer watching you know
documentaries and here's like a
documentary you got to watch first like
yeah it's all about meeting people where
they are and make sure that you know
they're able to consume
um something about basic income in a way
that they prefer
and that um reaches them based on you
know be their
liberal or conservative or libertarian
or green party or whatever
um there's just so many different angles
to
to get people to understand so people
want to support you scottsdale.com
um what do you see as like the next
couple of steps in the movement
uh and uh i'm so grateful to you man i
mean like
going through this journey with you i
mean you've taught me a lot uh i
genuinely do like people are like oh
andrew yang's mr ubi and it's like
sort of actually thanks god i think
scott deserves that title more than i do
but
um but yeah like how would you recommend
that people best uh support the movement
yeah that's a that's a good question and
um
yeah i think number one key is
is first of all you know becoming more
educated
on the topic so you know just like my
own process was i didn't want to like
start speaking about it
or you know writing about it do anything
when i didn't feel i knew enough about
it and so that involved this educational
process
of doing a lot a lot of of reading
and um you know first so i always think
that's key
is definitely learn more about it so you
can speak about it because you don't
want to
it just it works so much better to be in
a conversation with someone and be able
to answer
all their questions instead of being
like i don't know i hadn't thought about
that
you know that kind of thing so education
important and another part is yeah
finding the the right thing for you um
being you know at least donating to
organizations is definitely very helpful
if you can't do that you know there's
there's just so many other things you
can
um you know write you can um
you know contact you can be like become
that person
my preferred method is just to open the
just to open the window and just start
yelling
some variant uh i i you know i change
what i yell
i can scream uh you know uh
cash for all basic income give people
money i change it up based on the day
just open the window up and just yell
i'm mad as hell i'm not gonna take it
anymore without a basic income
for me a couple of things i've concluded
number one is just act
take action of some kind it doesn't even
matter what it is to scout's point
just like do something um that you can
then turn to and say well that's what i
did
and if it's something that you are going
to do uh repeatedly or that you're going
to
end up spending time on great but you
know
just just know uh yourself and what you
uh
you know like what is going to work for
you and just do that thing
um it can be buying a copy of a book and
giving it to a friend
uh you know it can be taking a news
clipping
um or a podcast recording and trying to
send it to people
yeah it can be engaging on social media
and just like you know
a like here and there a view here and
there like
that was something i feel that was um
that the yang gang utilized well during
your presidential campaign was
it was making a point of making sure
that people knew that they should click
on stuff
like if something is about something
that you think that there should be more
of
i mean that's what we're in this like
click view world
and you know that's part of the problem
but we can leverage it
to be useful by making sure that stuff
that
it talks about basic income that's best
especially that's a pretty light
ask scott very narcissistic scott's like
like my [ __ ] that's what you could do
the highest use it is true that if some
because one of the things that is out
there is that journalists write about
ubi
and then if you amplify their stuff then
they're more likely to write more about
ubi or something else
i mean you know that that that is a
thing yeah one of the things i'm going
to throw out there scott
and this is the way my mind works and
this is uh foreshadowing
for um you know where i'm going to turn
my energies to next
but i believe we've won this argument
i believe at this point everyone's like
wow we definitely have the money
it definitely helps people we should be
doing more of it
and so the question is having won the
argument having gotten to a point where
a majority of americans are for it
how the heck do we get it done and and
that is
uh to me the next question we have to
answer but we wouldn't be at this point
without you my friend
congratulations on the nuptials uh
congratulations on
being hopefully the first of
approximately you know a couple billion
prototypes
of universal basic income recipients
it makes you smarter more attractive um
you know we should do it for everyone
um but yeah man congrats on everything
i'm so happy for you and katie
and hopefully we'll have a chance to
celebrate together in person soon
yeah thank you i'm just so excited about
this and i'm excited for all the people
out there you know as of yesterday that
started getting
these checks i mean if you've got two
kids that could be
500. you're getting this check jump up
and down and say i love this check
and if anyone tries to take it away from
me i'm going to vote them out of office
that's a very good recommendation
yeah yeah definitely and make sure that
everyone knows that that's extremely
popular
and you will not be voting for someone
who somehow tries to get rid of it
and that's the that's the thing like
each each win builds on the next win
and we just had some big wins yesterday
we're going to get some more and you
know we'll get there um
hopefully sooner than later but really
like you said it just feels like it's
around the corner and
if we just get enough people involved
and we remove the obstacles
that you'll be helping tackle this next
and pushing for that
if we get those obstacles removed it's
going to be so much more possible
and just so many other things become so
much more possible too
yes we've won the argument now it's time
to win
the future thank you scott santons thank
you
appreciate the heck out of you man thank
you appreciate you too
and uh yeah it's just great to see you
[Music]
again
[Music]
you